you said uh viruses are kind of um
passive
non-living you could say
uh or even cells are passive and humans
are kind of active we seem to be making
our own decisions
so let me ask you the why question what
do you think is the meaning of this life
of ours
oh there's no meaning it just happened
it's an accident
i think there's no life elsewhere
because this is just a rare accident
that happened in the right conditions i
mean people all think i'm wrong because
there are billions and billions of stars
out there right so there's a lot of
opportunity there's no meaning it's just
a do they call it a perfect storm of
events that led to molecules being
formed and eventually i mean it took a
long time for life to evolve right yeah
but it's just driven
by
conditions if something emerged that
worked it would then go on to the next
step there's no meaning other than that
the only difference is that we
and i think many other animals can
probably we we have the ability we're
sentient right we can influence what
happens to us
and we can take medicines right we can
alter what would normally happen to us
so we can remove some of the selection
pressure
but i think everything else on the
planet just goes you know looks for food
and uh give a lot of offspring so you
can perpetuate it's just a natural
biological function yeah they're much
more directly concerned with survival i
think sure humans are able to
contemplate their mortality we can like
see that even if we're okay today we're
eventually going to die and we're we
really don't like that
so we try to come up with ways to uh
push that deadline farther and farther
away well we have really
i mean we used to die in our 30s right
and now it's 70s 80s well most of us
used to die
in our
in the first few weeks that's true
yeah infant death
i i
always tell people the only thing that's
100 is death
that's the only thing in in the world
that's a hundred percent think about
your own mortality i never think about
it i'm just enjoying
day to day and i don't really you work
on viruses you don't contemplate
your own mortality given the the the
deadliness of the virus i i
around i never thought covert would kill
me no i never was afraid of that not at
all i um
i mostly feared for other people getting
sick especially people who could die of
it i didn't want that to happen to them
but i always thought that
it's obviously a not a realistic
viewpoint not to be worried
because many people are
but i've been relatively healthy um
they should sequence my genome because
it works really well and have a good
immune system maybe you'd be the first
immortal person because i don't think
that's got to be a first so i don't
think so
i think that
biologically you just can't you know the
ends of our chromosomes keep getting
shorter and shorter and that's
eventually what kills us
um so you just can't keep going on
but um that's fine i i don't need to
i understand from the vampires that it's
not good to live forever
i guess make the most of the of the time
you got that's the uh bacteria live a
much shorter time so we got that on
bacteria bacteria are
just you know little bags of chemicals
that that split so they have no
they have no um
stake in the matter at all it doesn't
doesn't bother and i think you have to
go a long ways before you get into some
kind of consciousness but yeah it's
weird that this bag of chemicals
has a stake in the matter like our human
body
is uh consciousness is a weird thing not
just in us but they make half of the
oxygen on the planet 20 of the oxygen
comes from bacteria
um
and they made in the beginning of earth
they made enough oxygen to start
oxygenation going life going i mean it's
they have an incredible role it's all an
accident just happened
well
vincent like i told you i'm a huge fan
it's a big honor that you were talking
with me today thank you so much for
coming down thank you for spending so
much time with me
um and thank you for everything you do
in terms of educating about viruses
about biology microbiology and
everything else i can't wait everybody
should check out vincent's youtube
watch his lectures listen to the podcast
it's truly incredible thank you so much
for talking davidson my pleasure
you